[Applause]
[Music]
well
i mean i think it's different for
everyone but i hope that it you know
takes you away for two hours but when
people tell me afterwards that they've
had
you know an emotional experience and i
feel like a lot of people have had
these kind of brief encounters or
moments in life that um
that aren't part of your real life i
remember i think my dad
told me about always leave when um when
it's a part that you like so that you're
excited to come back to it don't like
exhaust the good parts just start it so
the idea you don't wait for
permission you just do um you just do
things and hopefully people will follow
yeah i like um making stories from or
kind of building an atmosphere for
from little moments and details and not
having to have a big
dramatic plot
and i think it feels i think you try
different things and you know when it
feels right when it fits as you're
writing
you know i think you you feel it when
you like it when you don't
want something's off then you keep
working on it until it feels right and i
always think it's more interesting when
the audience can fill in
things like and i also think people in
real life in life like in movies they
always say their feelings and i'm like
people don't say their feelings most of
the time so how do you show what they're
feeling
through what they don't say or what the
with the action of
with some behavior and i'm so interested
in the
spaces in between and and what people
how they express themselves with it i
feel like
yeah a lot of times people don't really
say what they're feeling directly so
i didn't want him to say it like this
all meant so much to me has changed my
life you know i think
you convey that and then the audience
can can put their own
version of that uh and but i do
i do think um i think there's a balance
though because
i don't know when i made my first short
film you're trying not to be obvious but
then
and that just doesn't really it's not
that clear and people don't you want
people to understand what's going
on so i think if there's a way to be
clear at the beginning
so that the audience can attach to your
story but
hopefully you can find other ways to for
them to express themselves um
and look and i think observing in life
how how people
do that when if you're at a family
dinner and
someone can say something that means
something really different so i think
part of it comes from observing how
people relate to each other
and a lot of times people aren't clear
or don't express themselves
directly i think my dad was always so
heroic on set that um and so
into being an artist and
making it happen so of course i um
admire that there's a funny interview of
my dad when i'm like
five or six years old he's interviewing
me asking me questions my mom walks
through and she says
because you're a wonder woman you know
you don't remember all your childhood
memories but that kind of um
that that was the attitude that they
were very encouraging and yeah and i saw
that my dad
never gave up he was always really
persevered and
i don't know lately i've been trying to
start a film project and i'm waiting for
the
company to give me the go ahead and he's
like just start it so the idea you don't
wait for
permission you just do um you just do
things and hopefully people will follow
how much of you was in this um there's a
lot of me in it there's a lot of my
personality
and what i like and my experiences and
what it's all about
yeah i mean even in choice of tokyo yeah
and even
the locations that hotel is a hotel
otherwise they wouldn't let you shoot
there bro i think so
but it in what other way is this a is
this a reflection of you and who you are
and what you're about and your
sensitivities
i think in the way the idea of um
the romantic aspect of it what i think
is romantic and and what do you think is
wrong
and that i'm a romantic and and my
second bill murray and he sees himself
as a romantic and
i think that's what we put into the
movie but um
i don't just it kind of it's kind of
like a i think it's almost more like an
older romance from you know i liked
humphrey rogar and lauren bacall
and some of the movies in the 40s and
50s yeah so it has a kind of innocent
romantic feeling that i think is in
there but
i don't know what it says about me but
it's you know accommodation it reflects
um
i mean yeah it's what i think is funny
and what i think is
beautiful colors and and use the music
oh i find writing the hardest part and
um i
and i procrastinate a lot and it's
really hard to be disciplined and
i um my friend tamara jenkins who's a
writer told me about
a program called i think it's called
freedom where like it cuts off your
internet so you can't get distracted
um but i i i don't
i don't know when i get into something
like with this i i went to the book and
i started marking it up and
and then choosing what i wanted to keep
and what i didn't want to include
and then um and then i would yeah kind
of rough it out and start
i really like using final draft because
as soon as you start working at final
draft it looks like a script so it's
really exciting
and then it makes me want to keep going
and i figure you just have to
um yeah get get enough to um
just to get through it so for me
adapting is easier than writing an
original script because you don't know
where you're going on this
i have a you know basic idea and
something to work from
and but i don't i don't have i don't
think i know like how many pages a day
or how long it takes i think once you
kind of get
excited about it then i would get you
know excited to go back to it and get
kind of obsessed with it and
i remember i think my dad told me about
always leave
when um when it's a part that you like
so that you're excited to come back to
it don't like
exhaust the good parts and leave it
apart what's going well
leave at that point so that you're
looking forward to
coming back to it yeah i like making
stories
from or kind of building an atmosphere
for from little moments and details and
not
having to have a big dramatic plot um
i don't i don't even know if i would
know how to do that if i tried so i i
guess i'm just um
i just write the way that um i know how
to
or makes sense to me and it's just kind
of collecting little moments and ideas
um almost like a collage or i like to
make photo books
with reference photos like a mood book
when i do
when i'm writing the script and i feel
like i approach the screenplay the same
way i just put together
moments and ideas and then hopefully at
the end it's
enough for a movie why tokyo
you wrote the script so you created
tokyo yeah i
i spent time there in my 20s and i it
always made a great impression on me
it's
there's nowhere like it that i've ever
been to and it's so strange and exciting
and i always wanted to do a film there
that you know you just click with
certain places and to me i met a lot of
interesting
creative people there that that got me
into different music
and photography and it just it feels
like a very exciting
modern city and so into style and
just people are compact yeah and it's
just like
and in the extremes of so modern and
then an ancient temple next to this neon
craziness but it's really like being on
another planet so
you started with characters or did it
start with sort of a tokyo tokyo tokyo
yeah start with the idea of tokyo i
wanted to shoot there and also just the
my friend they were singing god save the
queen and karaoke in tokyo just the kind
of combination of
different cultures and americans being
there and then i
within that i wanted to do an intimate
story between these two characters and
something romantic that is about a brief
moment that you can
meet someone and spend two days with
them and that can be just as important
as
someone you've known for a year adapting
material and you mentioned that it was
like a puzzle for you
um and when you're doing that is it an
interpretation
or do you feel an obligation to feel
true to the text or how do you balance
the kind of oath
that you take with that story right
obviously virgin suicides you were
passionately drawn to and so it's as if
you
and i love that impulse too of like i
don't want somebody to screw this up
like i know
i know this i don't want somebody else
to screw it up but how are you relating
to the material
and your vision of it yeah i think
you're just looking at what
what you connect to and it what you love
about it so i think the first time you
go through and
just underline parts that that strike
you
or um and then it just it's just kind of
weeding away and editing out
what you don't need and how how are you
going to
convey it into um story and
you take the dialogue and then kind of
rework it but i guess it's just it's
just going through and
and that's what feels like a puzzle or
it's like a game like how are you going
to take this and make it into
the visual version of it and and and
getting rid of things and combining
characters and
um that has how to keep the essence of
it but you have to
kind of reform it and i think it's just
about drawing out what you
what you love about it and what could be
told or how to
tell in a visual way sometimes it'll say
the characters thinking this so
how do you show that and that becomes
sort of a puzzle to figure out do they
say it to someone else or
can we show visual about what they're
doing and and
just it's just how to change it into a
visual yeah i can
yeah whenever i finish the film but when
i think about
um what the next one is it's always a
reaction to the one
before it or i found and that after
maureen twinette was so
kind of elaborate and decorative i
wanted to do like the most simple
minimal movie
that i could and and somewhere came out
of that idea of how simply we could tell
a story and then after the bling ring
was so
in that kind of tabloid world i
it was pretty ugly and i wanted to i
really want to make something beautiful
and in a really different mode and when
i started thinking about the story
picturing the
the the setting of um really shooting on
location and
wanted to do something more a little
more um
beautiful and elegant hopefully after
that world
yes making this film was definitely um a
reaction to after i made marie
antoinette after all the decoration and
all the people
involved in marie antoinette i wanted to
make a movie as simply
as possible and with as few people as
possible
and and very minimal so i i
i set out when i was writing it to make
um
a very minimal simple story with
the music is stark and everything about
it also with marine antoinette it was
so much my feminine side and so girly
that i
wanted to write this story from a man's
point of view
talk about music for you and where it
comes into your process and if it's
written
are are pieces written into the script
you know was i want candy written into
the script
i think i think it was i remember
there's some lesson they tell you like
never write it in the script because
then you'll
they'll try to cut it'll cost too much
because they'll know you need it in
there but
i definitely have pieces of music in
mind for certain sequences and
you know that's the fun part i've always
i've always loved music and
going to concerts when i was younger so
even when i did my first short like part
of putting the music together makes it
kind of come alive and have energy and
um yeah and it conveys so much of the
feeling
but um yes so i've always as i write
i'm listening to music and when i was
writing virgin suicides i was listening
to
errors for album and that's when i
thought oh maybe i could ask them to do
the music for it because
it felt like this um i wanted the film
to be a memory not set in the 70s so how
to use contemporary music to
but to feel like this kind of dreamy
memory
feeling about it so so yeah
i think about the music and the visuals
early on and that um
and that kind of informs the the tone so
all of my
team can we can all be on the same page
of what the feeling as
i i even give music to the actors and
play music on set
and wild i wanted to really
be to be sparse and tense and the lack
of music i think
gave a different feeling um and i also
think in the editing room
um sarah flack editor i always work with
who i love um we always try to cut the
scenes without music and make it work
because i think whatever you put music
on
it always makes it seem better so i
think that would be something i would
um just pass on as a good habit to
make your scene work without music
because it um
it can be used kind of as a crutch too
oh you talked at length about like
the lessons your dad and your cinematic
family has sort of imparted on you
but what are the things you had to like
unlearn from them or
shy away from doing to sort of create
your own style
oh that's a good question i never
thought about that because i
i feel like i i learned a lot just from
being on set
and um and then things that you know my
dad talked about but when i
set out to make my own film it really
came from what i was interested in and
so different and you know my my
personality is so different so i
i am i just thought about doing it in
my own way and um and there's a story my
dad came to
set on my first movie and was saying
like you need to say action louder they
need to know you're in charge
and and i was like well this is how i'm
gonna do you know so you have to find
your own
way of doing things so if i didn't ever
feel intentionally i mean i would i
would never make a
gangster movie i just you know like i
would never i would never go on you know
he's
um so as far as shying away i probably
wouldn't
yeah i wouldn't take on material that
he's the great master of but i
you know i always felt like i i was
drawn i do
just try to do things you know
what interests me and how how i relate
to the world and how i would approach
[Music]
them
you